und wir wollen jetzt schalten zur
Krankenschwester Biljana redlich guten
Morgen Frau redlich sie sind
Krankenschwester habe ich gerade schon
gesagt und sie sind sehr wütend auf die
Politik warum das
guten Morgen ja ich bin sehr wütend auf
die Politik weil seit vielen Jahren nur
über die Pflege Reform debattiert worden
ist einfach nichts passiert und diese
corona-zulage von 1500 Euro haben wir
schlichtweg nicht bekommen wir sind
einfach angelogen und das macht mich
rasend
ja und gerade jetzt in der Pandemie wird
ja ihr Job noch wichtiger wie haben sie
dann während der Pandemie arbeiten
müssen
und wir haben natürlich schon unter
erheblichen Voraussetzungen hygienischer
Maßnahmen gearbeitet das lief ganz gut
muss man sagen natürlich waren die
Mitarbeiter
gestresst und ja es es ging aber es war
natürlich schon eine Herausforderung
wie sieht denn ihr beruflicher Alltag
aus vielleicht könnte das so ein
bisschen beschreiben und auch die
Belastung konkret
wir arbeiten natürlich wir alle
Krankenschwestern im drehschichtsystem
das heißt früh spät und Nachtdienst
das Problem ist dass wir seit vielen
Jahren keinen Nachwuchs bekommen es hat
einfach schlichtweg keiner mehr Lust
diesen Beruf unter diesen Bedingungen zu
erlernen es ist einfach minderwertige
Bezahlung die Personaldecke geht stetig
zurück und daher Spahn der passt einfach
das Personal an dem Patienten an man hat
immer mehr Patienten zu versorgen und
das ist schlichtweg nicht mehr möglich
es ist teilweise fahrlässig was wir auf
Station machen
haben Sie denn das Gefühl dass sie und
auch ihr Beruf wertgeschätzt werden
nein unsere Beruf wird nicht
wertgeschätzt wir haben jetzt
Hintergründe b-zeit natürlich geschenkt
Präsente bekommen wir haben man hat für
uns geklatscht aber dabei ist es
geblieben man hat uns mittlerweile
wieder vergessen
bei den Streit geht es ja um mindestens
150 Euro mehr Gehalt reicht das
die Frage ist immer was ist gerecht für
diesen Beruf natürlich sind 150 Euro
nicht schlecht aber es ist natürlich bei
weitem nicht die Anerkennung die eine
Krankenschwester ein Krankenpfleger in
diesen Beruf verdient da müsste man
schon ordentlich was aufpacken um den
Beruf attraktiver zu gestalten sprich
das auch wieder Nachwuchs kommt
Dankeschön Frau redlich für Ihre
Informationen und alles Gute für sie
vielen Dank
mehr Nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei Bild schau dir hier das nächste
Video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren